en un esfuerzo por recomponer los lazos
el presidente turco recep tayip erdogán
anunció el pasado viernes que se reunirá
con mohamed bin salman en ankara zone
este miércoles el príncipe heredero
mohamed bin salman tendrá su visita
vamos a dirigir reuniones bilaterales
con él y su delegación tendremos la
oportunidad de discutir cómo mejorar las
relaciones turco sauditas a un nivel
superior en el futuro los dos hombres ya
se reunieron en arabia saudita en abril
un encuentro en un momento en el que
turquía ha estado buscando socios para
hacer frente a una grave crisis
económica y al aumento de la inflación
antes de la primera visita un tribunal
turco transfirió el caso -ha shogi a las
autoridades de riad a petición del
ministro de justicia turco llamado
giorgi periodista saudita opuesto a
mohamed bin salman fue asesinado en
octubre de 2018 en el consulado saudita
de estambul la onu concluyó entonces que
fue brutalmente asesinado por un equipo
de agentes sauditas enviados desde riad
la gira regional de bin salman se
produce tres semanas antes de la visita
de joe biden a la capital saudita que
sigue a pesar de haber calificado al
reino de estado paria
no voy a reunirme con mohamed bin salman
voy a una reunión internacional al menos
vamos a formar parte de ella al igual
que hubo gente que formó parte de la
discusión de hoy
después de una fase de aislamiento tras
el asesinato del periodista saudita el
príncipe heredero busca poco a poco
reavivar las relaciones con diferentes
jefes de estado de todo el mundo